agreement but not on everything that's  the message from the visit to athens of  european parliament president martin  schultz the first by an eu leader since  syriza won the election in greece he  held talks with prime minister alexis  tsipras and progress was made  president schultz praised the plan to  tackle tax evasion but he told a greek  newspaper he's not happy with syriza's  right-wing coalition partner there was  disagreement too on russia and ukraine  and disputes over debt must still be  resolved  in  these are early days for greece's new  government and their scope for  disagreement with eu partners but at  least the talking has begun